each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so it's with a lot of pleasure I
that we have two visitors from the
University of Illinois they're both
being funded under the Intel Microsoft
university computer center project qpcr
see Robert barchi no and Vikram at V and
Robert will be giving the talk today on
deterministic parallel Java and Robert
is a graduate student in the pure
science department I guess at the
University of Illinois interested in
parallel languages and compilers and
particularly looking at safety and
performance of parallel languages and he
has a ba in mathematics from university
of heart harvard university and most
interesting he actually has a law degree
from Harvard too and decided to abandon
the law and come over to the dark side
and engineering so I'll let bra Robert
take over thanks very much good morning
everyone pokeno and I'm going to present
some work today that I've been doing at
Illinois with Vikram my advisor and
several other people and the title of
the talk is deterministic parallel Java
towards deterministic by default
parallel programming all right so I'd
like to begin with a very short
introduction on the concept of
determinism so the idea of determinism
in computer programming is that the same
input is always going to produce the
same output and when you do is
particularly when you're doing compute
intensive work a lot of algorithms
actually have this property or mostly
have this property maybe with a few
exceptions and so what we're talking
about here is going to be a
non-interactive computation that means
you're you're giving it some input it's
computing it's producing some output
also its characteristic of this type of
application that the parallelism is
going to be for performance so it's not
part of the algorithm specification but
you want things to go faster on multiple
cores so some examples include
scientific programming games voice video
AI etc etc there are lots of examples
like this languages can also be
deterministic so by deterministic
language I mean that if you take
program and you pass it through the
compiler and everything checks then the
program that you get has this
determinism property and examples
include purely functional languages so
something like a parallel Haskell also
there are simdi models that are
deterministic so Fortran 90 95 CUDA for
the NVIDIA GPU would be an example of
this there's also some explicit data
flow languages so sigh soul is an
example also intel has this thing called
concurrent collections that they're
working on that's kind of a data flow
model okay so I contend that
deterministic languages are really
important for several reasons so one
reason is that if you have a
deterministic language and therefore
your programs are all deterministic then
you can reason about them almost
sequentially even though they execute in
parallel determinism eliminates a lot of
subtle parallelism bugs you can avoid
all sorts of complexities like data
races deadlox complicated memory models
that can kind of make your head hurt
it's also very simple to test
deterministic programs because there's
only one output to check / input so the
problem we hope is about is easy or
difficult as it would be for regular
sequential testing and also it's
hopefully it's going to be easier to
port sequential to parallel code because
you might still have to make some
changes to expose parallelism but
hopefully the ported program is going to
look an awful lot like the original
sequential program so if you've
thoroughly tested your original
sequential program you hopefully have a
high degree of confidence that the
ported program is correct and it's also
simpler to reproduce bugs and do
debugging again because you can mostly
think about it in a familiar sequential
way so the overall point here is that if
you can guarantee determinism for
parallel programs then parallel program
becomes simpler okay unfortunately it's
not so easy to do that and in particular
it's not so easy in the case that you're
updating shared memories so if you have
a program say like an object-oriented
programming where you're passing
pointers to mutable state around and you
have multiple threads going and they're
reading and writing
then it's hard to provide static
guarantees of determinism because it's
hard for the compiler to know what's
going on it's also possible to add
runtime checks that can rectify this
problem but one time checks have their
own problems either have to do them in
software or hardware if you do them in
software you're going to add extra
overhead because you have to check all
these reads and writes if you're going
to do them in hardware the extra
hardware you need might be complicated
might not be available on all platforms
and also I contend that if you're only
relying on runtime checks to get this
determinism guarantee then you will get
the correctness but the performance
analysis and tuning are going to become
harder because you might be you know if
you're speculating or if you're you're
checking things and you don't know
whether the program is going to run or
whether it's going to fail that just
makes things harder right so you'd like
to do as much statically as you can
although it may not some things may not
be possible statically so for these
reasons I contend that the widely used
languages today generally don't
guarantee determinism so if you think
about something like C Java you know C
sharp things like that generally there's
no guarantee and it's it's just up to
the programmer to make sure if they want
the determinism that they have to do it
themselves and make sure it's correct
and test it okay so this leads to the
project that we're working on at you by
it's called the terminus Nick parallel
java or DPJ so I've put up the sort of
main bullet points here about the
project's about so the first point is we
want to try to introduce determinism
into a modern object-oriented language
so we chose Java for this exercise you
know we could just as easily have chosen
something like C sharp or C++ or any
other object oriented language we think
you know job is a good choice so the
idea is to have the compiler guarantee
determinism by default so it's an
explicitly parallel language but we want
it to be deterministic and we want the
compiler to guarantee that and as I said
before the the goal here is to use
static type checking as much as we can
so so part of this research exercises to
sort of seating okay you know what can
we do with static types and what can we
do
and so we kind of want to really push
the boundaries on the static type
checking but then when we see that
that's not working well or that might be
a little impractical then we also want
to be able to fall back on runtime
chicks as the sort of a second line of
defense we also think it's important to
allow limited non determinism and I'll
talk about this more a little later but
the way we see it is there's basically
two kinds of non-determinism so one is
where you know you have non determinism
going on in some part of the program
that might be encapsulated in the
library or a framework and maybe the
programmer doesn't really have to worry
about that so from the programmers point
of view it just sort of looks like a
deterministic computation kind of at the
interface level but there's some you
know fine grain locking or something
going on inside and then the second kind
is where the programmer actually needs
to think about the non determinism
because it's in order to get more
parallelism you need to need to allow
that kind of at the client level an
example that would be like atomic
transactions right okay so here I've put
the broad research goals of the project
and then once I've stated these and I'll
go through them in order and sort of
talk about what we're doing for them so
the first research goal is how to
guarantee determinism by default using a
combination of static and runtime checks
a second research goal is if we have is
local non determinism how do we
encapsulate that and make sure that the
rest of the program is safe and
deterministic assuming that there's some
sort of guarantee provided by the
encapsulate piece and then the third
point is how to specify explicit non
determinism when that's what you want
and how to make the non determinism in
the determinism interacting wait you can
reason about and then the fourth point
is more of a usability point it's how to
simplify porting to a deterministic
language and that also includes just
writing programs in a deterministic
language so you want to make it easier
to write annotations reason about the
parallelism and so forth and we think
that compilers and development tools can
really help with that all right so now
on the first point of guaranteeing
determinism so our fundamental approach
here oh and by the way I think I think
we have plenty of time for this talk so
if you have questions at any time
go ahead and yeah look so go ahead so
police are you hurting do you think of
their parallel programs for arbitrary um
could be both yeah so Brett yet so I'm a
little later i'll get to some examples
and it should make clear service so we
haven't yet you know study the full
range of parallel programs and we've
sort of focused on certain subsets but
the the goal here is to make it very
general and to support just general
parallelism yeah but obviously you know
the more on structured it gets the
harder it is to do things with the
static type checking so that's yeah and
where we are okay so yeah so you see
compiling down to a bag and then just
scheduling does the nose of those day in
terms of Nora get Carlos that's
currently not the way we do you could do
that the way we do it now is we compile
to the fork Joint Task library in Java
so we basically you know have us we have
a source of sorts transform and we just
have something that basically has
library calls that spawns the tasks but
yeah you could compile down to an
explicit dag and then that might allow
you to do some analysis optimization on
the dag but we don't currently do that
okay so the idea here is we want to have
an explicit type and effect system where
we define what we call our regions and
then we use those regions to partition
the heap so that kind of gives a way to
specify what's what in the heap space
and then you can use the region's to
annotate methods with effects summaries
that say what pieces of the he / being
read and written and then once you've
done all that then the compiler can
check that the method summaries are
correct and also that parallel code
sections are correctly synchronized so
there's no read/write interference going
on it's going to violate determinism
guarantee and we also have some runtime
support so so so the main kinds of
runtime support we need our first of all
to do fine grained synchronization like
producer-consumer synchronization you
know we just need some run time
synchronization context struck to
support that and I'll talk a little bit
about what we have for that so far and
also in some cases if we can't provide a
static guarantee then we need some kind
of runtime support that's just going to
do a check and you know check for
certain sanity conditions and if those
conditions aren't met at runtime then it
would just stop with it you know either
produce a warning or stop stop executing
okay so now i have a very simple example
of regions and effects just to kind of
get your head around how they work so
this is a very simple sort of toy
example but it illustrates some of the
basic concepts so what I want to do here
is I've got a class C that I've defined
and it's got two fields f1 and f2 and I
want to declare two regions so these are
names r1 and r2 that I can use in this
very simple example to just partition
see objects into two pieces and I've
coated them you know red and blue so our
one is blue and r2 is right and then
pictorially is illustrated over here
that you know on the heap at runtime I
might have something that looks like
this right okay so that's how I
partition heat basically I declare these
region names and then I can put the
fields in the regions okay then once
I've done that I can use the region
names to summarize the method effects so
I've got a method M one that is
assigning to f1 so its effect summaries
rights are 1 and similarly I've got a
method M 2 that's writing to feel too so
it's summary is rights are two and then
once I've done that I can have another
method that invokes those first two
methods in parallel with the co begin so
this just says you know do the two
statements in parallel and then the
compiler can use the effect summaries to
infer that the effect of this method is
to write R 1 and the effect of this
method is to write r2 and r1 and r2 are
distinct names so in this case it can
prove that there's no interference and
everything's good so this is kind of a
very simplest example of how you would
use effects and then in a little bit
i'll get into some more complicated
examples that come up in sort of in real
codes okay so then so that I like to
talk about some of the interesting
parallel patterns that we can do so you
can use effects to do a number of things
and you know I'm not going to talk about
all of them here today because some of
them are pretty simple you know some of
them are known so they're very you know
very useful ones that are sort of very
straightforward but I'm going to talk
about the ones that sort of new or
interesting that we develop as we've
been doing this work so here are four of
them so one of them is a parallel update
so you've got an array of disjoint
objects and you want to run over the
array and update all the objects in
parallel you know going through the
references and what's hard about that is
you're following references right so so
you won't do that the second one is to
distinguish disjoint parts of nested
shapes so if you have say like a tree
and there's some notion of you know a
left subtree and a right subtree kind of
under the root and then you want
traverse that tree in parallel and
update it how you how can you prove that
at
it is a tree and because of the data
structure and the traversal pattern
update is safe okay another example is
divide and conquer operation on an array
so that's similar to the tree data
structure example except that you're
taking an array and chopping it into
pieces so you're basically making it a
range with tree so you can think about
something like quicksort for that and
then the last example is you have a
fine-grain data-dependent
synchronization so you know something
like a sparse matrix or something where
you have you know the sparsity pattern
governs the pattern of data dependences
and so you don't know statically what
the pattern is so you need some kind of
runtime mechanism to synchronize that
but you want to make sure that the
coding and the runtime mechanism are
working together to give you the
determinism and so that's an example
where the runtime and the types is to
work together to provide the guarantee
yeah one of the examples today so that
was you have a very simple partition
pattern but it changes over a different
basis every right can you support
um I guess I'd had to see more
specifically what the example is so
that's yeah I think in some cases we can
do simple divide and conquer huh but in
the marriage face you want to also
paralyzed that part and you would have a
different rotation for the do it so I
think in some cases we can do that like
I'll show you an example of how we can
do for instance like quicksort where you
can you know you can partition an array
dynamically into different chunks so we
can handle something like that but
there's other cases where the static
type system isn't as flexible as we'd
like it to be because in some cases we
kind of have to say at object allocation
time okay you know this object is primer
eyes with this region this other object
is parameters with that region and if we
want to change those regions currently
we can't do that so it's a limitation we
probably need to add more runtime
support for that so I'll talk about some
examples that illustrate this just one
way you but you know columns in
violation for lumbersexual code rosa
that we could probably do that yet
because like in that case you know we
could probably partition it into rows
and columns and then you just say okay
I'm you could just specify columns rows
the difficulties come in where you you
want to just you know you're doing one
thing and you just want to do some
totally different thing okay but so the
point of this slide is just that we've
developed some novel patterns you know
we we looked at some codes we saw okay
we want to do some things with these
regions and effects and we said okay in
order to express these common patterns
you know we need to develop some new new
techniques so we've done that for some
of the patterns alright so the first
example so now going to sort of go
through each of these four things in
order so the first idea here is updating
objects through an array and I contend
that the key property and doing this
kind of update is what i will call
linearity of references so this is
related to the concept of linear types
but it's different so it shouldn't be
confused with that concept and the
reason why I call it linearity is just
because if you look at the data
structure data structure itself has a
linearity property where each object is
only pointed to by one reference in the
data structure but there could be
arbitrary other objects and local
variables and so forth pointing to these
objects so it's not it's not some sort
of global linearity requirement like you
again in linear type system but it's a
linearity requirement when you just kind
of look into the data structure and I
contend that that's the property that
you want if you're going to do this kind
of update in parallel you know in the in
a straightforward way otherwise you know
to do something like this you need some
more complicated synchronization if you
wanted to do it deterministically
because you'd have to ensure that let's
say this one went before that one but if
it's linear then you can just zoom
through and do them all in parallel so
in dpj well the goal is if you have a
linear day structure you want to express
that linearity requirement so that when
you do the parallel traversal and update
the compiler will say ok that's fine and
the way we do that is we have a novel
array type where we leverage these
things called region parameters there
are a lot like Java generic parameters
this is parametric polymorphism so we
have a class C parameterised with some
parameter P so we just extend the you
know the type parameters that you get in
Java with these region parameters and
then we can say something like cell I of
an array if it's one of these special
linear arrays than cell I can have type
C parameterised with region I and so
each cell the array is actually going to
get a different type and then we can use
that typing to enforce that I is only
ever assigned I so you can't for
instance a sign you know I plus k2 I and
then that enforces linearity requirement
so to look at a simple code example here
I've written a class parameterised with
P and I have some update function that's
doing some update to the object that I
don't specify but what's important is
that it writes p so here at see I've
declared the effect in terms of the
parameter so when this class is
instantiated with some region then the
affair and effect of invoking the update
on the instantiated class is rights
whatever that region is you just do the
substitution to get the effect okay so
then okay then here's a pictorially sort
of what it looks like you know I want to
have
an array of these seas I want the zeroth
12.2 a sea with a zero bound to it and
the fourth one with four and so forth
okay yeah and does that mean that all
fields of the press of an allocated
instance are allocated in that region um
sure uh okay so not not necessarily so
just going quickly back to this example
so remember here like I could say you
know field f1 is in our one field f 2 is
in r2 so what when I declare a parameter
like that it just becomes another region
name that i can use so i could say you
know I could say in f1 and P so I like i
can just probably the code that it
allocates this yeah a so I in Regent's a
lie yeah I mean that's right that so
that's one way so I didn't specify you
know exactly what this update is but
want you know one thing that could be
going on here is you could have some
field like X that's you know int X in
pee and then update could write to that
field and then it would it would write P
or you could have a whole bunch of
fields all declared NP and I could all
be updated and that would also be
covered by this effect right okay so
then in the simple example of the
parallel traversal and update there's
basically three things you need to do
right for the pattern so the first one
is you need to declare an array and it's
going to have some type and the type is
going to tell you that the array has
this linearity property and the
linearity property is going to be
preserved by all uses of the array so
that when you finally get to the update
it works ok so the type annotation we
have here is just we just put an
underscore so this is somewhat
preliminary you know we're still sort of
hashing over exactly what the syntax
should be but this seems to be one
reasonable way to do it that you just
need to put something in there to
indicate this property that says that
when this array is instantiated and you
take the the ice element out of it the
type you get out of it is C primer eyes
with I ok so that put an underscore to
indicate that all right so that creates
a linear Claire's linear array then you
want to create and initialize well
so I haven't actually shown the array
creation right but you would just say
new to actually create the array and
then you want to initialize the array so
here I have a for each that just does a
stride one traversal from zero to the
length of array a minus one and then I
can just zoom over that and create a new
see parameterize with I on the I
Federation and put it in and the
compiler can just do this very simple
symbolic comparison and say ok yeah
whatever I is you know this is going to
equal fee equal to the size so the
typing works out ok and we can do more
complicated examples but it would just
be sort of limited by the symbol come
you know the symbolic comparison
capabilities but what we found is in a
lot of cases you just have you know
simple comparisons like this so it's
just most mostly like a bookkeeping
thing it's just sort of documenting that
you're following this pattern correctly
and then the last thing you want to do
is go again zoom over the elements and
update them in parallel and in this case
as I indicated before the compiler can
infer from this use and this declaration
over here and the static type of a right
so you put all that together and you get
that on the ice iteration the effect of
this method call is rights region I and
since the traversal here is at stride
one and you're just going in order you
know over the eyes on a different
iteration you get a different eyes so it
works ok so it's sort of putting
together all the pieces to prove the
determinism X to the 4th to the formula
all the ace alive
two times i plus five yeah you can do an
arbitrary thing it's just that you know
if you really push the bounds of the
symbol comparison and the compiler might
not be able to prove that they're equal
and then it would just complain and say
I can't prove that these are equal full
linear functions yeah that things like
mod divided like that would come back
with a false well I would have all the
problems I mean we haven't really like
investigated this specifically but it
would have you know whatever the
problems are and you know for like
dependence analysis that you get into
yeah so I'd assume that like affine
functions you know like ax plus B would
probably do just fine and then other
things you know be harder so yeah okay
so then just to go into a little more
depth so when I presented this material
at Illinois last month there was a
question about sort of what happens when
you have multiple pointers pointing into
an array so this is an example where
I've got two whoops sorry where I've got
to reference variables right that are
pointing into the same linear array so I
can do something like you know it's okay
to go over the array and update it and
then I can go over there and update it
again that's fine like if I just said
sequentially but then if I want to do
those two things in parallel that should
be illegal right because the reference
is alias okay and the way I know this is
because I if I look at the effect of
this entire statement I know that it's
writing you know regions I oh that's
what I know about it and I know also
know that this statement is writing
regions i and I can't distinguish the
region's I that those statements are
writing so I say that's not allowed so
the compiler is in not all that but if
you go to a different example where you
have two different references pointing
to two different arrays then you can
distinguish them and the way you do it
is you so there's this extra information
we allow here where we can actually
parameterize the whole array so it's
kind of like a class region parameter
you can just think of the array is like
a special kind of class and so there can
be a parameter for the whole array and
then this one can say well okay each
element is in region I but the whole
array is also in our one and then so we
use this nested syntax here so and a
little bit i'll explain more how this
nesting works right but the basic idea
is just that we can within an array we
can distinguish like zero from four and
within this way we can distinguish 0
from four but we can also distinguish
this whole array from that whole array
because this one is our one and that
one's are two and then I can say all
right it's legal to do that again and
it's also illegal to do the co begin all
right yeah you're going into more and
more specialist types question is uh if
you go like two slides back yeah you
question is how do i get to CEO I it
seems like I would be a little bit
Australian creating that in a manner
that's reusable buffs multiple loops or
users right I just want to call function
gives me a seat right in most cases but
he's finding the function kiss me see oh
boy right so what you have to do or it's
kind of like dependent types right so in
order to do that you have to somehow
pass the I in and then get the I back
out yeah so or you have to pass in
enough you know you'd have to pass in
something and then get back some
function of it such that you could prove
the aquatic and use some symbolic
comparison to prove that it's equal
right ok example of an injured person
bow dr end yacht right in this case
outside
yeah well so in this case I mean the are
you probably be able to get from the
type yeah but you'd have to pass each so
are in that case would either be some
global name that you could just refer to
or it could be something that's bound to
a class parameter or a method region
parameter so it's where it's kind of
like Java generics right you can you
name the type or it can be parametric if
you want it to be scoped or you want you
want to reuse it with different names
and you create a parameter and pass it
in so that basically that the I index
thing works an awful lot like these
names it's basically the same kind of
thing except that you have this extra
wrinkle because you have you know it's a
run time value so you don't you don't
have as much information about what it
actually is it's not just a name it's a
value so okay um all right so then to
conclude the linear arrays example so
there's a couple of extensions that
we're thinking about this sort of
address some limitations here right so
the first one is that you know this
works well for some common simple cases
of updating parallel arrays but in
general we're going to need more
flexibility so for instance if you want
to take an array and permute its
elements we can't really do that right
and still maintain linearity because
we're requiring that we only ever assign
you know if an object is created with
region I then it's only ever signed into
the i'th position of any array basically
so one way we could do this is we could
just maintain some metadata in there in
the array and just check that the same
element isn't inserted twice and then if
it isn't sort of toys we can complain
right so the user could say i want this
array to be linear I think it's linear
and then I run time you can just check
and see whether it's leor not so that
provides more flexibility but the
guarantee is weaker because if it turns
out to be not linear than you have to
stop yes
thought about it and I've played around
that a little it's just that that
introduces a whole lot of other
restrictions so I I do have some ideas
on things to do with linear types but
that's sort of more exploration of work
yeah so how do you is something that
isn't as descriptive and as you
expressed by age yeah I think so linear
types are nice because like big for
instance linear types wouldn't have this
problem right i mean you could perm you
things and since you only have one
reference outstanding it's no problem
there but then aliasing becomes really
really hard i mean i found that when you
start programming of linear types and a
lot of times you end up programming in a
very functional style which is okay but
it's just not the way people tend to
program in java you know you'd have to
like pass something in and then you
always have to give it back it's like
you send it in and give it back and it
means you end up having to rewrite a lot
of common patterns so it's just a
trade-off yeah okay so another important
extension to this is to extend it to
more general collections right so right
now we only do basically dense indexed
denser raised right so dense index
structures we'd like to do spar
structure sets maps things like that
things that aren't necessarily indexed
so it's just a collection you know it's
a collection of things right with a
little less structure so one way we
could do that is we could extend our for
each constructs so that you're just
iterating over the elements of some
collection like a set and then if we can
guarantee that or if we know somehow
that each element of the structure
structure is unique like it's in its
asset so sets are supposed to have this
property of course modulo the issues
that come up an object comparison is
always a tricky thing like because it
depends on the semantic definition of
when two objects are the same but
assuming that you only have one of each
object in the set then you should be
able to do this and you should be able
to just extend the idea so that this
underscore thing becomes an implicit
parameter that's bound kind of bound to
the iterator right instead of being
bound to like a numerical index so we
think we can do that
alright so that's all I had on linear
arrays now I want to go on to this
nesting concept which is the sort of the
second point that I was talking about in
the parallel patterns okay so so I
showed this a little bit in the array
example so the idea is that we have a
tree of regions in the region so the
region nesting forms a tree and this so
this is an example of how we could do it
right so so we have a root region and
then under root we can have something
like root kool & R 1 a root colon are
two and then under root colon are one we
can have more nesting you know with a 0
and a 1 and similarly over here and we
can just sort of combine that it's very
flexible that you can just combine these
names and arbitrary ways and create
these things that we call region path
lists or our pls so the ideas you know
something like root colon a cold B is a
region path list because it kind of
denotes a path in the tree and when you
see something like rucola nicole and be
you know syntactically that that's a
nested under rucola day so that the
nesting is sort of its impact the
comparison and the importance of this is
that you know as we've already seen in
the array example you need to be able to
group regions right so you need to be
able to say like I want to distinguish
this 0 from this one here and that 0
from that other one but I also want to
be able to distinguish like these two
from these other two right so just
provides that kind of flexibility okay
so as an example you can make a tree
data type so you can you know not
surprisingly you can use the tree region
trees to make an actual tree so here's
how you do it you declare a tree object
that has one region parameter P you can
declare a Regents Ellen are you have
some data you can put that in the in the
P which is the parameter of the class
and then you do this tricky thing with
types right so you say the left
reference is going to have two
attributes it's going to be in region
pcola hell so this says you know the
region that's nested under P that's
named by starting at P and then L okay
and then you're you're also going to say
that the type of that left is a tree
that's bound to pcola know and similarly
for the right one and then at run time
that might expand out to something like
this right so to see how this expands
out you just start plugging in for the
parameters so you might instantiate a
tree whose root is bound has
it's parameter bound to the root region
and then you would just plug root in for
P and all these things and then you know
you say okay the data is in region root
the left thing is in region rucola know
the right thing is in regional Buccola
are and also you know that the type of
left is tree with parameter rucola nel
and so that's indicated by this arrow
here right and then so you know that so
that's a static restriction on the
assignment you can do so this has this
property that ok now rucola Nell's bound
to the p and again you substitute in and
same thing for the right one and then
because of this nesting property and
because L&R are always different and
then you know you have a tree yes I
could also just choose to place left and
right the fields and just in p right
okay you do that yeah you can do that
right well it could still traverse the
subtrees absolutely okay yeah and
another thing you can do to make it a
little bit you know if you want if you
need a little more fine-grain
distinction is you can declare another
region that's the region of the links so
you could put all the links in a region
and then the effects can say you know
i'm reading the lengths and I'm but i'm
updating the data regions in parallel me
do things like that yeah okay so then
right so that gets to this which is a
very simple example of how you can
specify tree like effects so this is the
same tree up here that i showed before
with a little picture of the actual tree
and then the boxes show that the
groupings right so this shows how at the
at the root like sort of looking at
things from the perspective of the route
I can have the left subtree in the right
subtree and I can just and I know that
they're disjoint like you know nothing
ever points across at least nothing that
I'm following so that's one thing about
the system is you can have arbitrary
pointers going across these regions
right it's just that you have to declare
what you're doing so if you ever follow
one of those pointers across you have to
say you're doing that and then you lose
the tree structure of the parallel ISM
but if you're not ever doing that then
you can specify that and then the
traversal works fine so in this example
I have an increment method that's just
going to
zoom down the tree and update in
parallel just increment all the data in
all the nodes right and I can do this
because I can do the left subtree
independently the right subtree and then
similarly with the recursion so I have
the way I do that is I can infer when I
do left increment that I'm writing p
cole and el cajon star and i confer when
i do the right down increment that i'm
writing p coal in our cold star right
and i get this from two things it's the
type of the dispatch object left right
so here it's like pcola no that's that's
his type and then i plug that into the
declared effect of the method which is
here it's recursive right but the method
is declared with the right speak won't
star so when I plug pcola Nell in for P
and P gold star I get people at elkins
are all right and then when I do that
it's an easy matter to infer that people
and el cajon star and people and oracle
and star disjoint for any binding to pee
right so that's the key point I don't
statically I don't know ever what
exactly that p is but I know whatever it
is I can make this inference and it's
sound okay all right so that's all I had
on that the nesting in the nested
effects so next I can go on to the
divide and conquer operations so this is
a similar kind of concept but you're
just doing it on a flat array instead of
a tree so to do this we introduced a
couple of language features so we have
something called a sub array which is
pointing into a sub range of an array so
it's basically a view and so this is a
concept that Java uses in other contexts
where you know have an array and then
you have another object that points to
the original object but it it just looks
like a contiguous subset right so and
then it'll compute the offsets so that
you can just index into the subset and
then it'll compute the proper index into
the underlying thing and then we also
have a partition which is a collection
of disjoint sub arrays so you can take
an array you can chop it into to just
just joint sub arrays and make a
partition out of that and then the
partition object kind of knows the
disjoint is property and can use that to
infer the correctness of the updates and
then in a type system we have that each
sub array in a partition is going to be
in a distinct region and we can use
recursion to make this flattery into a
tree of regions and so that this aspect
of the type system is kind of like
object ownership
so we're basically making a tree of
objects instead of a tree of static
names okay so very quickly code example
here we're using a method parameter it's
kind of like a class region parameter
but it's just on the method Java has
something very similar for generics so
the method is going to take one of these
special arrays that is parameterized by
a region and it's going to say it writes
under that region then it's going to do
some bookkeeping stuff for the quicksort
algorithm and this one is actually going
to have an effect that writes you know
that this method is actually writing the
array because it's shuffling your way
around then I'm going to create a
partition out of this array so I'm going
to have two segments and then I say open
here just to indicate that i'm not
including the actual index position in
the in the partitioning right so i have
this left one in this right one not
including the pivot and now i can
traverse them in parallel and update
them and the type system is going to
tell me that that works so and then we
have this type where we can actually use
a variable as a kind of like an art very
basically using local variables in our
PL and that tells you that you're using
the objects references as the tree and
that that's what allows you to do this
dynamic partitioning ok all right so and
then the last thing I wanted to talk
about briefly so oh yeah sure glad Oh
calm in third cycle so sighs DPJ ringing
yes so column yeah so what were the six
there
each other right okay so that's what i
was mentioning that the so what you can
do is you can make a local variable here
cigs right and you can assign a
partition to it and then you can use
that local variable as as it sits as a
region name yeah and so it works kind of
like I don't know if you're familiar
with object ownership but it's works
kind of like that and you you're
basically saying that the object
reference right that lives in that
variable is the region okay
yeah so actually one restriction that we
do have which all right so this is a
little misleading so I should have put
this restriction in here is that we
require it to be final so should this
should say final just because if you
start reading and writing you know if
you start writing different reference in
and then you have different uses you
could do data flow analysis you know to
prove that things are the same or not
the same or whatever but just to make it
simpler we just say well if you're going
to use one of these variables as a
region then you want to make it final so
you know that every use is always
referring basically we're for any the
same thing right
have the type
if the called method used the formal
parameter name in this way could you
have it be the same type as
did the caller yeah that's an
interesting question so we can
definitely do that in the case where
yeah so I think that's basically what
we're doing here right because well no
actually so here we're just doing it
with a method region parameter so I
think you definitely can get something
like that in the case where you
substitute for this I had an off the
thing about that a little more I mean
you know if you're interested we can go
through some examples and so because you
definitely do some variable substitution
you know when you're in at the point of
a method call that definitely happens
okay so the last point I wanted to talk
about on the parallel patterns is this
fine grained synchronization so this is
very preliminary work I mean writing
right now this is sort of an idea that
we have for how to handle this and we're
looking at into how this might work for
something like a sparse cholesky
factorization code but just to
illustrate the point I have a much
simpler example here so the idea is we
have this region that we can declare
with the sink keyword and then that's
actually going to create a runtime
construct that's used for
synchronization so all the regions i
showed before were erased they are all
just static things that the compiler
would check and then get rid of right
but this is something that actually
hangs around at runtime because in this
example you need some synchronization to
do this deterministically right you want
to enforce that this access the XS
through one to see goes before the
access to five so to do this have class
c with some data that's in this sink
region I have some work method that's
doing an update but now I'm saying dist
are so because it's a sink region it's
at object granularity so I can say this
dot R and then I can have a parallel
work that takes an array and now I'm
running I'm using a task spawning style
here which is a little different than
what i showed before so I'm running over
the array sequentially and then spawning
some work on each of the elements and
what's so what's going to happen here is
the runtime is going to
this work okay so the key idea is that
there's a queue associated with each of
these sync regions and so in this case
you know you get one sink region for
each object you create so each object
has a little Q associated with it and
when you do one of these spawns the
spawn is actually going to put the
declared effect so it's going to infer
what the effect of this spawn statement
is and in this case it's you know writes
this dot R so its rights avor but at run
time that a of I is going to get
resolved to a reference and it's going
to follow that reference and it's going
to find a queue and it's going to put
you know rights referenced are on to
that or rights are on to that q and then
and then continue and similarly when it
gets to three it's going to do the same
thing but when it gets 25 it's going to
put that effect on q1 but it's going to
wait until the first one is done before
it can proceed and that's what Garen so
so basically the sequential order of
issuing the spawns together with the
ordering property of the queue is going
to guarantee that its execution is
deterministic and it's also deadlock
free yeah yeah
two best buys a lolz so first best huge
fuel yeah definitely good and right so
there are a lot of issues with making
this efficient I mean obviously don't
want to do this on every element right
you want to have some sort of
partitioning efficiency purposes and um
yeah work here you're saying q1 and q3
if the two seeds were C sub a and C
Sabine really the right way to think of
it as cease aveda q & c sub b duck you
it's not not associated with the array
indexes right its associated with the
object right and the op and the objects
get resolved at runtime so that it sort
of saves the compiler from having to do
some very complicated alias analysis to
prove now you know you might be able to
do some aliasing ounces to optimize
things like you might be able to see
okay well since I'm already waiting on
this Q I don't actually need to wait on
this other cube or something like that
but this is sort of the basic mechanism
is you just leave it you leave the
object reference distinctions to the
runtime mr. pres collation yeah right
also sparsely gets
doing as possibly part of this unknown
until hard time so the actual data
dependences become dependent on the 0
and this positive bacteria right exactly
what happens in sports journalism to a
colonization column of means depending
on which ones are parallel dependencies
yeah so tentatively like the next thing
I'm going to be working on for my thesis
is like looking at how to apply this
idea to sparse Jaleski that's kind of
what I'm doing right now great it's far
so good the first guy Yeah Yeah right
basically at the point where you put
something on the queue and you see that
you're at the head if there's nothing
else there then you drink only to all
the other bowling I need another guns
too
okay so i can talk very briefly about
the implementation we've done so we've
developed a preliminary compiler that
does a DP GA to java translation it
extends the java c compiler from sun and
it uses the fork Joint Task framework
which is a library written by Doug Lee
and others I guess that it's supposed to
be part of Java 7 that's not part of
Java yet just yet it uses a work
stealing task scheduler so it's similar
to silk and we have a few benchmarks so
we actually have coded up some other
benchmarks but these are the ones that
we use for the performance numbers so we
have a standard mergesort implementation
a couple of programs from Java grandi
benchmark suite a Monte Carlo simulation
and an decryption algorithm and we have
a force computation which is the most
compute intensive part of the Barnes hut
and body simulations used a lot in
astrophysics and we have a collision
tree algorithm from a graphics engine
and to do the experiments we used a four
by six core x86 machine with two gig
memory per core for all but the graph
the graphics engine which needed some
more heavy-duty graphic stuff so we used
an apple mac pro for that but we're
actually working on trying to get this
to run on the dell so that we can have
uniform numbers for all the all the
benchmarks okay so i apologize if this
graph is a little hard to read hopefully
you can see what's going on but you can
see that the numbers are kind of all
over the place right so basically we
have two applications that are doing
quite well that's the ide a in a merge
sort we have one application that's
doing okay and not great that's Monte
Carlo the thing is that the Monte Carlo
just has some scalability limitations
built into it that are even in the
javathread implementation so we're
equaling or exceeding the performance of
the java threads with that one so this
in some sense it's not our fault right
that this is not scaling so we're pretty
happy with those three barns hut right
now is very very disappointing it's just
not scaling at all and we are there's
actually a couple other students at U of
I been working very very hard on trying
to figure out why this isn't scaling but
our best understanding at this point x
it is some
to do with the actual Java that it's the
JVM that basically there's a student who
actually wrote this out in Java threads
and it still is not scaling so it seems
to have nothing to do with anything that
we're doing in dpj it's just a
performance issue that we need to solve
in order to make progress with this
particular benchmark and then for the
collision tree it's scaling ok and then
it seems to flatten off it's just kind
of hard to tell because we're only
running it on 74 is there ok so this is
basically what I just said we're still
working on Barnes hut ok we did get good
performance for at least a couple of
them really 43 we got good performance
so that's encouraging ok so now going
back to the research goals so the next
issue is how to encapsulate the local
non determinism and so for that there's
basically two kinds of encapsulation so
one is you know something like a some
reduce wear this is what I said before
right where you just have a
deterministic operation and there's some
non determinism going on inside that
operation but the client really doesn't
care at all what you know what's going
on in there then the more complicated
example is if you have something like a
reduction or commutative container
operation where there's there's some
interaction between the encapsulated
code and the client code so you know
maybe the client oops maybe the client
is applying providing some operation
that's going to be used for the
reduction writing and maybe the library
is going to require that that be an
associative operation or you know maybe
the you have a set that has a
commutative insert method but the
parallel client code nor take advantage
of that has to know which ones commuting
which ones don't and the compiler has to
know that in order to check things ok so
on the example of commutative operations
so we actually have an idea here on what
to do and we've actually I've actually
worked this out so this is part of our
type system so we add a commutativity
annotation on methods that commute right
and this is something that a library
programmer would provide so we
anticipate that a skilled programmer
would write some sort of library that
would have a commutative method and then
there be some sort of you know extensive
testing to make sure that the
commutativity
correctly implemented and then that fact
would be recorded with an annotation
this ordinarily is not something that
you know Joe average client is probably
gonna be writing but then what's going
to happen is on the client side when you
invoke one of these methods the compiler
can see the commutativity annotation and
the compiler is also going to record
what we call an invocation effect so
it's kind of extending the concept of
effects from you know reads this writes
that too does this method with such and
such effects so you've recorded both you
know what you're reading and writing on
the heat but also which method calls
generated which effects so that when you
get something like this you know where
you're in parallel doing a bunch of
setad's the compiler can say okay the
effect on iteration I is you know add
with right a right to whatever region
the set is in and the regions are all
the same and those are all rights but
because the set add is declared with the
commute that's green that's okay but
then over here if we did an ad and a
fine in parallel you know that could be
non deterministic so that's not allowed
and another way we could get at green
clearly is if we you know did a set ad
on one set and asset add on a different
set you know we could just use the
mechanisms I showed before to just
distinguish those two sets right but
where the where you're doing it on the
same set you need this annotation all
right and then so moving on to explicit
non determinism so now I'm getting into
the part of the work that's a little
more preliminary so this is more in the
nature of you know ideas we have for
things to do we haven't worked out in as
much detail how to actually do it so our
idea here is that okay you know we
recognize that some algorithms are non
deterministic examples include branch
and bound search the Lani mesh
refinement which is I believe this is
one of the stamp benchmarks and it's
gotten some attention in the literature
graph clustering is another example so
basically what's going on here is that
you know you have a problem it's a
compute problem so you're giving an
input and producing output but you might
want to tolerate some non determinism
you know you may want to say okay well
any any one of a class of answers is ok
because if you restrict
one particular answer you're just
limiting yourself too much and you will
lose performance and you might seriously
whose performance so you really don't
want to do that so you're giving up some
determinism to get performance so in
this case usually it's one or more
phases of a larger program and to
support this you need some kind of
transactional or other non deterministic
semantics okay so we have some
requirements you know we want to
eventually want to allow this kind of
thing but with some limitations right so
we want it to be explicit first of all
this is really important because we want
the programmer to say that they want it
and if they don't say that and they
don't get it we want it to be data race
free so that you don't get kind of low
level interactions that are hard to
reason about and we also wanted to be
confined in the sense that we'd like to
be able to look at the structure of the
program and also together with the
semantics of the constructs we provide
we want to ensure that there's no
interference or at least unwanted
interference between the deterministic
part and the non-deterministic part so
some examples here I have this for each
s deconstructs OSD here means schedule
dependent and it's just extending the
for each construct to relax the
requirement that the iterations be
non-interfering so that you know
everything is deterministic so here for
this one interference is allowed you
know you can have conflicting reads and
writes on the different iterations but
if you do that there's going to be some
kind of atomicity enforcement you know
we'd probably be in the nature of
hardware software transactional memory
kind of thing but what's important here
is that even though we've introduced
some non determinism here right this
part is deterministic at least when you
look locally at what's happening in this
loop so if there's some data that's
being produced here that's used in the
next block that might introduce some non
determinism right because this ant this
could produce a non-deterministic answer
but but you could still look at this
section of code and reason
deterministically about it and we just
think that's very important and
similarly over here you know you can put
the 4-h inside
for HST and even though there's some non
determinism going on in this whole block
inside the block you know that let's say
on some iteration of this for hsd you're
going to do a for each and inside that
for it you're going to get deterministic
results so again you can reason locally
about the determinism even though you
introduce non determines and so we just
need to work out in more detail you know
how these mechanisms are actually going
to work and be implemented and so forth
this is sort of our ideas at this point
okay and then the fourth point that I'd
like to touch on briefly is this concept
of making things more usable helping
programmers right right the region's you
know figuring out how to annotate things
and also maybe where the code needs to
be revised in order to expose
parallelism and so forth and in
particular how to take legacy code and
port it to a language that uses these
concepts so our sort of broad vision for
this kind of porting environment is that
we want to leverage parallelizing
compiler technology that's that's been
well studied and well developed you know
it hasn't really caught on in the
mainstream but we believe that's because
of some limitations when you apply it
you know if you want to do things fully
automatically it introduces some severe
limitations that hopefully we can
overcome by making more interactive
right so that allows programmers to
verify choices right so the compiler
could say well I think this is you know
going to work and the programmer can
look at it and see whether that's true
and we believe that that can hopefully
circumvent the fundamental weakness of
auto paralyzation which is basically
that you know auto paralyzed and
compilers have to be very very
conservative because anything they do
has to be guaranteed correct also the
types of inference that the or no
analysis that the compiler is going to
be doing is going to be a recommendation
so it's going to be interactive in the
sense that the programmer can see what's
going on and not just some black box
transformation that just you know not
something like okay you know I
vectorized this looper I didn't
vectorize this loop it's going to be
sort of more hopefully provide more
information
about you know what what went wrong or
where things might need to be changed to
make it work things like that so
hopefully there's going to be high level
changes and also allow programmers to
understand what's going on so that they
can kind of do a feedback loop where you
know look at some results from the
compiler and then think about some
things to change then feed it to the
compiler and and so forth and also we
think it's really important to produce
readable maintainable code so you want
to preserve comments macros things like
that so that you know you're not just
generating unreadable code because I
would sort of defeat the purpose of
having this interactive loop ok so for
DPJ so first of all this vision is a
very broad vision for reporting
environment for a deterministic language
it's not even specific to dbj it's very
very high level but start working on
this we're starting with dpj as a target
and we're starting with something very
basic which is affect inference so you
might have noticed that in the system I
described before you know it's somewhat
heavy on the annotations in the sense
that you have to write everything out
even you know method effects some reason
all that and we believe that's the right
way to start because that's how you can
you know hammer out the ideas and make
sure it works and prove it sound and all
that but then sort of once you've taken
that first step then I think you really
want to work on making it easier for the
programmer and one way to do this that
we believe is going to be fairly
straight forward is to infer the method
effect summaries at least in a lot of
cases right so the programmer can
declare the regions and the region
parameters but then the compiler can
look at a block of statements and just
you know some just record all the
effects going on and then insert the
summer into method so it should make the
language more usable okay and the next
step after that is to actually infer the
regions and that's a much harder problem
because really what you're trying to do
there is look at the parallel access
patterns and say okay you know for
example this part of an object is being
accessed in parallel with that other
part of an object so therefore I've got
to put those two parts of the objects in
different regions right and that's
something we're in order to do that
reasonably well it's probably
require a fair amount of interaction
between the compiler and the programmer
because the program is going to have to
bring his or her knowledge and insight
to the problem you can't just like throw
that a compiler and spec it to work well
but hopefully you know if we make it
interactive then it should be tractable
at least in them you know important
common cases okay so in conclusion so
I've presented an overview of this
project that we're doing dpj
deterministic parallel Java it's an
object-oriented tired of language where
the compiler is guaranteeing determinism
with some runtime support present an
overview of the research agenda so that
mainly includes expressing determinism
expressing controlled non determinism
and dealing with usability issues and
porting issues and I showed some
preliminary results including novel
features of the type system very
preliminary performance results and some
ideas for extending the language that
we're working on that's what i have so i
can take any more questions yeah go
ahead actually I've ever faced
I you're talking about d to mystic so
what kind of talk to you looking for
will allow you to derive the
deterministic and pushin it sounds like
you're looking for the protein and the
updates to the different regime which
equal to deterministic that's yeah well
right so I guess how I would summarize
the property is so there's two basically
two I think two properties one is that
you have like disjoint concurrency right
so like you're doing if you're doing a
for each then the reads and writes the
conflicting reads and writes are
disjoint right so right so basically for
any like for any pair of memory accesses
happening in parallel either the axis is
commute or they're disjoint right and
then the other property would be you
know for this fine grain synchronization
thing you might allow some interference
like that but you have some
synchronization mechanism that just
makes sure that you know the right
always happens before the read that
needs to access the right things like
that that's how I would summarize it
property yeah yeah that's a very good
question so right now we are just you
know using the ostrich algorithm just
just ignore it right no but so I so
basically I I believe that I Oh can be
done in a similar way right i mean you
can you could have i oh regions just
like you can have memory regions mean i
guess like the simplest way to handle I
oh and get safe safety right is is just
to say well anytime I do an i/o
operation inside some parallel region
right that that could be potentially
conflicting but that's you know it's
very limiting for instance like you
wouldn't be able to do parallel I oh
that you know that might be okay if you
don't have a parallel io system and you
don't really want to be doing parallel
Ohio anyway and so we think that for a
lot of these compute intensive
applications you know probably the model
is read a bunch of stuff into memory
compute on it and write it back out and
we can handle it just fine if we needed
to do
some sort of parallel io stuff then I
think the you know I think the model
could be extended that way yeah um
cyclones visited uses at least the name
regions for it yes similar color yeah
and they try to use it largely to prove
the safety of memory de-allocation right
yeah I wondered if you thought about
whether the ideas are similar enough
that you could give some of the things
they get out of their regions yeah I
think you definitely could yeah right so
region-based memory management is is
closely related to region-based
non-interference stuff which is what
I've been talking about I just think
there are some differences because the I
think the use patterns are different
right so I mean I think it would be
useful to look at something like cyclone
and say okay you know if we wanted to
design a comprehensive language that
could do what cyclone is doing and do
what we're doing you know what would
that look like that would definitely be
a useful thing to do and there's
definitely some definitely some overlap
way to do this in putting agents in
their kind of language I think is a
little easier because they appeared for
regions he only pays
here we have to add and Lachey patterns
between friends and in addition to that
so for example so that tree example 3
example you'd have to inform that the
objects actually all fall retreat to
cause shame analysis to be able to do
then that's quite different oh okay yeah
sorry don't non-determinism Jews and
concurrency yeah but what about non
determinism due to interactions within
runtime system you also require like the
operating system to beat it down this
day now so how would you do that yeah so
basically you know our thinking on that
is that we're going to tolerate whatever
kind of non determinism is sort of
already in your sequential programming
model but are you thinking of maybe
non-determinism that would come in
because of like parallel connection is
in you are you receiving data from the
socket a break it up a packet which
other tonight kids can you just think of
the back is like well I think so in that
case I guess it depends on what you're
doing I mean if you're doing if you're
doing some computation that's actually
the end result of which is intended to
be deterministic right then you would
have to encapsulate or sort of insulate
that particular non-determinism in some
way right you'd have to say okay I'll
get the packets in different order but
at some higher-level you know the the
way i compute on them doesn't really
matter the order doesn't really matter
you're the order which ever see them
doesn't really matter or something if
it's really non-deterministic then you
would explicitly you know you would
explicitly request that kind of
non-determinism so i guess it just it
really just depends on the application
right so we haven't really looked at say
like network applications it's just not
something we've studied so i know i
guess i don't have a really good
specific answer for that application but
that's sort of the general way we go
about it object hash codes
great so we haven't run into that
particular issue but my sense is that
you could use something like the
community annotation that I showed
before right so the commutativity
annotation that's specifically for data
structures but the way I showed it right
but you could do something similar you
know you can have an interface that
wraps some little localized
non-determinism like I'm generating hash
code or i'm updating a counter or
something and you can do you could
declare that you have a little bit of
non-determinism that's tolerable there I
think what I have run into is that
defining the semantics of that can be
pretty tricky because like in the case
of a set you know the set semantics is
actually deterministic even though let's
say that individual operations going on
inside our nondeterministic in the case
of like a hash code or updating a
counter or something you may actually be
introducing a little bit of
non-determinism at the algorithm level
but i think the right way to handle that
again is to fall back on this principle
that says well if you want that kind of
non-determinism then you're allowed to
have it but you have to say it right so
you have something that clearly marks
like at this point the program I'm
introducing a limited amount of non
determinism and then hopefully you can
still reason you know because people do
this right they introduce little bits of
non-determinism to their code and it
doesn't interfere too much with your
ability to reason about the code you
know if you if you have a little hash
code or something like that it's not you
know it's not like you know a data race
can occur anywhere in the program and I
just had no idea what's going on so yeah
okay
condition of the ridges are court
assigned here so I understand that in
samel grid which are in some sense well
structured it natural associated
looks like there might be more other
organs which that don't allow easier
definition so how do you think it is
easy for the problem and to find these
regions and is it really easier just
five grand block super
oh well that's a really interesting
question I mean certainly if you put in
the region's then you get better
guarantees and you get with fine-grained
locking right because if you use
fine-grained locking then you're just
totally on your own right as far as
whether it's correct yes logically no
fire it's great yeah so the feeling
compound what is proportional village
which doesn't allow this logical
monster sure so it's a good question and
something we only learn by getting more
experience with more programs and
especially larger problem but in
practice you want paralyzed and food I
have to think about the sharing patterns
and they'll be putting in the region
annotations fundamentally involves that
because the region annotations are
trying to do are trying to partition the
heat in a way so that the sharing
patterns become explicit and if you
understand the sharing patterns in the
core enough to paralyze the i think in
doodle you should be able to put in
region annotations that capture that you
might be limited by how fine the rain
you can make the regions and then put in
effect summaries on the methods to get
the palace in that part i think we
already know that more experience but
analyzing what the partitioning of the
each should be more how it matches the
partitioning of the algorithm fabulous
and the algorithm that what I think
should follow from understanding the
Paris
just that something that's hypothesis
that may be similar to what composition
in front door right so and say expect if
you start with an assumption that I need
like a lock for these type of objects I
say okay all the methods right this
object that's the effect system and then
I try to do some proud algorithm of my
object and I see oh ok actually can't
have any powers and then I'm thinking
they may be any finer so and so you
could have that kind of iterative
process where you put in regions and you
find out that you're not getting enough
fascism and you have to refine them you
could also work the other way to put in
regions and you find out the program
doesn't type check because the visas
were actually to fight me and you have
two pencils there will not capture so
you have to make
so you could have an intuition and
either behavior could have but what's
nice is you will never get incorrect
answers like logs you put in regions the
new partition you write any parallel
code the type checker will tell you if
you have indeed write another thing
that's better than I think a little
better than what composition oh please
that you know why composition get this
infamous problem where there's like some
walking going on in there and you just
don't know what it is and when you try
to like use you know you try to treat
this encapsulated thing as an
encapsulated thing it has locks it but
here at least the region summaries so
that we believe actually this is one
benefit of having all the summaries is
that it tells you what's going on right
so you can hopefully reason about it a
little better so he had a question just
perfect life is the way you get to carry
them through the join pattern so
for some other application like some
interactive system like you gave me yeah
or like the server client right Neriah
the level of concurrency was among whom
are you get it depends on the user input
right or that using the action with a
client requests and the the server or
the need to response to this repair by
difference thread in that way in
that scenario how to apply the dbg so
we've been basically confining our
attention to programs that aren't like
that right that's that's sort of the
simple answer for now I mean so that's
why I started in the beginning and I
said you know focusing on these programs
that are like we call them
transformative or sort of non reactive
so that you know the model is you you
put in some input it does some
computation and it gives you some output
so if there's a lot of interaction with
the user then it's not really that model
but I mean I think some of these ideas
could be extended to apply to that kind
of model it's just that's not what we're
working on right now
yeah when you have a pencil
Oh
Joel classes have discs implicitly for
your photo so we could so that that sort
of a language design issue sort of a
usability issue that I've thought about
sort of gone back and forth on it you
know should should everybody have an
implicit one or not right now you have
to declare it explicitly and if you so
if you don't declare anything you just
don't get any parameters if you declare
one or more parameters then you can you
can instantiate a class with no explicit
bindings kind of like a Java raw type
right but then in that case you there's
just some default like I think I think
that falls just route cold star so it's
just like everything is just everything
right but another choice I think
reasonable choice would be maybe give
everybody an implicit parameter and
maybe you know make the default that
every every field is like implicitly in
that parameter right that I don't know
that might be a better choice I just I
don't know I don't know what the best
choice is like from a language design
point of view so I just done it this way
because it's kind of the simplest just
to you know illustrate the type system
for now yeah oh like except to the
penguin Lavinia's and not sometimes the
protocol Abedini Aristo stuff you know
what's the long time overhead compared
to the sequential normal java version uh
well it depends so for the static fully
statically typed linear ray it's zero
right but and then it for this other
idea that I have I don't know because
it's sort of a preliminary idea right i
mean there would be some overhead but
hopefully it would be pretty small I
mean I guess my you know my heard like
the runtime checked linear array I mean
it would be prepped something like a
bloom filter so it would be hopefully
very low overhead or are you know be
some sort of like bit comparison or
something like that
the one where you have two arrays the
interaction ya ready um queueing
queueing thing yeah I guess I'm a little
worried that you know it's going to be
hard to get the overhead of that to be
reasonable but we'll have to see so I
think my strategy on that is going to be
you know start like as i said i'm going
to look at sparse Jaleski start with a
good implementation of that you know so
to see what they do to get that highly
efficient and then see you know how i
can try to abstract up from that and
hopefully preserve as much of that
efficiency as possible right so yeah oh
uh i think it was over the well it's
over the parallelized code running on i
believe isn't that what we did or OS to
see oh it's a sequential version yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah cuz right because we have
the compiler yeah right the implemented
followed EPA does not include the sink
region
yes of course and you have any idea what
the performance just the wall
performance education families with
respective for chocolate ready for java
threads so not the speed-up of the total
time oh yeah I don't know off the top of
my head say what squish me just right so
you said your speed up for a little bit
better maybe than the javathread trying
horrible he an operable to will be
better money but what's the execution
time for the different movements and yet
compared to tell me they've gotta take
it you know oh I sent my faster but have
less speed up right or something well if
you're only if you're injecting grunting
shuts people want to know what's rachels
I think we use the same baseline though
for both I think it's the same I think
they're the same program like there
should be again as much as I'd into it
because we took the job
so we might not be entirely an integral
so it's a good core it's a good question
but there's nothing it seems like they
should be at least very very similar
right it's not like we're adding
shouldn't be adding any overhead yeah so